hi YouTube my name is camera chambers
and this is Tamra justice' I'm solo
today Cody and I couldn't get our
schedules together but that's alright
I've got so many other friends today I
went and saw a baby driver in the
theatre directed by Edgar Wright yeah I
did not know what I was in for
I've never seen an Edgar Wright film
I've never seen that whatever trilogy
and I've not seen Scott Pilgrim I've
seen ant-man which I guess he did some
early writing for and then some artistic
differences by the way I saw grindhouse
which I think he helped direct like one
of the short things in there but I
nothing of fulfillment and holy crap it
was amazing I tweeted about it right
after because I couldn't contain my
excitement but this baby driver is
definitely in my list of top 10 favorite
films which I need to make a video about
the direction of this film was out of
this world
there was not one boring shot everything
kept my attention everything was
incredible I think in so much filled
nowadays used to nut but nowadays I
watch a lot of content for for Channel
awesome and I'm just more interested in
films it's just these days you guys wore
me down
but I can't believe how intriguing this
film was to be oh my god definitely the
best camera just a film I've ever seen
by far the best newer film I've seen
this year the acting was incredible like
I said the stunts were amazing I think
there was a little CGI I feel like
there's no like big-budget film out
today that doesn't have any CGI in it I
don't remember
there wasn't blaringly in my face and if
it was it was really well done the actor
the lead actor on Soul is that his name
on Soul Elgort I don't imagine that's
how you say it
I saw him for the first time in The
Fault in Our Stars that John Green books
that was made into a movie because I
really love that book
and I thought he was incredible this was
such a different turn of events for him
a different role different just like
whole project and he nailed it he played
like this spunky silent but deadly hyper
focused character I can you stop
yodeling please I'm actually filming
right now I don't know what to say I'm
going to try to keep this spoiler free I
don't think I've said any spoilers yet
sorry if I have also I need to be better
about saying if the Tamra just saw are
going to be a spoiler for your knob I
know I haven't done that I'm so sorry
but I'll try to remember to do that
cheese Louise not a good reviewer
spoiler-free okay so the other actors in
it are incredible Jon Hamm Kevin Spacey
um J I want to say me fuck um we're all
great the only actor who I wasn't crazy
about was Lily James who played babies
love interest in this which started like
a little less than halfway through what
I would say and I just thought I hate
saying this I don't know what I didn't
think she was the right choice I think I
think she looked really great for the
role I don't think that the acting
really did it for me and that might have
been a script thing I don't imagine it
was a dirrection thing just because like
this directors nailed it on every other
account I also thought that the story
was really good I thought that I was I
was really into the romance I really
liked where it was going and how it was
written and like the pacing in it and
everything I just thought I didn't
really believe her a lot of the time and
I think I might just because there was
less of her than maybe maybe there's a
little rushed maybe maybe that's what
I'm now putting together in my mind
there was something lacking in that
department I don't really know what it
was I can't really pinpoint it but I I
still enjoyed the
aspect of the romance just because it
gave the entire thing such a good art
and you get to the end and it's really
important for you to care about all that
in the beginning and so it really works
well I just can't believe how well this
movie works it's so good I went so I
went to the theater today and I saw baby
driver alone and then I went it comes to
see it comes at night alone too as well
also lowly I did it good and and so I
was sitting there getting ready to watch
it comes at night and I was just bummed
I wasn't rewatching baby driver because
I was so pumped for it yeah quick quick
note on it comes at night I don't know
if it was that it wasn't what I was
expecting I don't know if it was that I
had jesting one of my favorite films of
all time baby driver for the first time
I don't know I don't know I don't know
hey cuz at night was lacking for me it
was such a cool concept I really like
when you go into films and there's no
exposition because we live in a time
where a lot of films get a lot of
exposition but it's like look we could
have pieced some of that together I
didn't need all of that and and this you
kind of just go in and you have to like
pick up the pieces and kind of figure
out what's happening and I love that and
then it just falls apart and the ending
is just like okay why do we care right
now like one of the characters there's
two characters that end up in the end
and one of them like I think you said
like four lines I don't care at all
about you some of the other characters
kind of like a cold-hearted carrot like
he's hard to do this no spoiler job I
just didn't really care very much about
it it left me with questions that I
didn't really care to be answered which
is weird they weren't I do
it's definitely dispensable there were
definitely moments about it I enjoyed
the acting was really well done I always
want to root for scary movies because I
love them and I love horror and I think
this is a good horror film but that's
kind of sad because
it's lacking a lot that you should say
you don't get that many truly wonderful
horror films that are coming out like on
a regular basis oh okay baby driver was
so good some of my favorite moments in
baby driver there's this one shot after
the first heist where baby is going to
get everyone in the group coffee and
it's pretty sure it's one shot where
he's listening to music oh it's another
thing
okay who's into your music and he's
walking to the coffee shop and then
walking back from the coffee shop and
doing like these great dance moves and
the scenery is really good that did the
shot looks incredible he's doing an
incredible job the music is incredible
this entire film feels like it's not
know one thing and people actually
people do sing but not well so it's not
like there are showcasing any voices the
soundtrack is crazy and it show
complements the movie to a point where
it's like telling a lot of the story for
you and it's like written into the
storytelling and into the story and to a
point where it feels like it's a musical
but no one's singing it was so cool I
have the guardians of the galaxy volume
1 soundtrack on vinyl
soundtrack comes out on vinyl I'm
totally going to get it the only
soundtracks that I have for movies the
one the Guardians month it's a really
interesting character that's been
written here it's through baby
he's like partially deaf and he's an
orphan
and she's crazy into music he's got a
little bit of an OCD thing going on with
where he likes to have things at all
times and he's got to have his music his
iPod and like he makes music and sells
me records that he just a very
interesting dynamic character but just
cuz he's like everyone else is also just
very interesting and dynamic Jamie Foxx
was so creepy and weird and like
aggressive and I hated him but man I
loved him like I love Jamie in the role
I hated the character Jon Hamm was
maybe my favorite john jon hamm
performance missus like possibly my
favorite jon hamm performance his wife
in the film was amazing and stunning and
just good like sultry and badass you
guys missed out on so many boss baby
jokes in this reaction video because
Cody's not here I'm going to kinetic on
this weekend's when this video comes out
I will be there and I'm hoping to see
spider-man homecoming with Malcolm and
hopefully we'll do a video there thank
you so much for watching go see this
film please it's so good is this how you
guys feel when you're like camera you
haven't seen that it's amazing go see it
because damn if you like I'm on a hype
train right now I feel like I shouldn't
say that it's in my top 10 favorite
films of all time but it was like a
religious experience for me seeing it
alright I'm gonna go think about my life
now and my choices and boss baby and
baby driver I'll see you guys next week
bye
[Music]
you